project for office you're gonna see a
lot of party poppers in the coming 48
hours that's good that's very good then
but don't forget your eyes I feel like
you guys haven't been donating because
you've been watching my face now because
I'm just controlling the front page
we're actually just doing good thing
[Music]
the problem that we're facing right now
is truly unprecedented we're reaching
the highest levels of displacement since
World War two Don we now our gay apparel
the Geena Davis Institute Liberty in
North Korea conscious period recycle
takes unwanted bikes from the UK and
transports them to where they're most
needed in Africa $3,000
Tallulah minced garlic chocolate chip
ketchup a monster
airing is one of my favorite foods -
wolf goes Bella but have you ever had a
lot of it in a room in a big hurry or
already love this because no tyler
oakley's but in so many places including
that bean bag when are you eating I'm
having some herring okay hmm
oh no I hit restart by accident Oh panic
help me obi-wan Kenobi you're my only
hope
it's goofy euphoria of non-navigable
rivets
Melanie got brought across in 2015 money
to keep those toes warm will likely Pat
the butter onto our face so this is six
eggs
Oh watch he's here thank you guys so
much thank you to everybody who worked
so so hard at the last 48 hours thanks
to everybody in the live stream we love
you happy project for awesome we will
see you in just 360 three short days but
it is over or is it the IndieGoGo is
still going on so you can that a project
for awesome calm slash donate and still
get all the great things that are
available pets of YouTube calendar the
project for awesome socks the
commemorative coins smashed pennies that
after midnight Eastern time tonight you
will never be able to get any of these
things ever again including all of our
very exciting and reasonably priced to
digital perks and our most popular perk
of the year the digital perk bundle
which has all of the digital perks
all-in-one and finally maybe most
importantly right there there is a
donation card that you can click on and
you can donate through that card and
that will still get matched by Google
are matching up to $100,000 than they
made a deal with the credit card
companies so that every single cent that
goes through that button gets passed on
to the foundation to decrease worldsuck
thank you so much to everybody who
participated this year whether you were
in the live stream whether you're
volunteering whether you donating
whether you're making videos it really
went so well with so much funds a great
time and John I'll see you on Tuesday
and you will see me again on Friday
that's a double week for me